what's up everyone Michael and Jake here
at PAX West 2019 and we just got
hands-on with Luigi's Mansion three
Guruji's Mansion three oh yeah
[Music]
now in our time with Luigi's Mansion 3
here at PAX we saw a new section of the
game that wasn't shown at e3 the way
they're describing it is each floor is a
different theme and this one in
particular was the garden theme so we're
dealing with like giant watermelons
explosive pineapples lows of pineapples
ones that bounced up and down you got
nailed pretty now we were playing the
whole thing in coop I got to play Luigi
you got to play demands Luigi he can't
open doors but he can go places
Luigi cans yeah so there's a there's
kind of a cool dynamic where the to
Luigi's are well Luigi Luigi can do
different things with in there so they
have to almost rely on each other
similar abilities for the most part but
like slight differences for an exit one
example is that we were able to I was
able to slip through a drainpipe and
check out this area underneath ball I
don't know you're blowing leaves or
something like yeah yeah I can open
doors those bazaars Luigi can't open
doors but the coop was a lot of fun yeah
it was a lot of fun I guess I could say
that I'm sort of surprised by how much
fun I had playing luigi's mansion 3
because there are so many variables
whether it's the puzzles or the combat
like between his vacuum and some of the
other things that Luigi can do there's a
really nice dynamic where I'm constantly
doing different things at each moment I
mean we only played about 20 minutes but
I did get a good taste of the different
things that you can do and yeah and we
got like a good mix of puzzles and some
co-op puzzles like one that I really
liked is when I took the chainsaw and
like blasted it with light in order to
rev it up and I was just destroying the
entire room and then you got picked up
by a vine and I had to save you that was
pretty cool
[Applause]
the movements a lot slower and it's a
little bit harder to kind of aim you're
like your vacuum that's the one thing I
did notice like especially because you
have those fixed camera angles between
room to room and your sharing screen it
is really tough to know exactly where
you're gonna be anything going back to
kind of the clever things that you were
doing though like you can aim the
there's like a plunger attachment and
that can lead to some pretty cool
puzzles like we needed to break a are we
need to bust up a bunch of water baby
yes big one so we can't like attach the
watermelons too directly to our vacuum
so we shot the plunger onto it and it
has like a little rope at the end and
then you you attach your vacuum to the
rope and then you start swinging it
around yeah or you can get many things
in like smash yeah it's busting yeah
that's what they busting makes Luigi
feel good oh yeah yeah when you're when
you're fighting ghosts though you just
hit them with your flashlight and then
you hit them with a vacuum they start
swinging them around that that's all
pretty good like it's a little violent
but you know yeah ghosts are trying to
get up all in our business and they get
what's coming to them yeah I'm excited
[Music]
[Music]
so in brief that was our experience with
Luigi's Mansion 3 it's come to
Nintendo's switch exclusively on October
31st 2019 stick to GameSpot for all the
coverage from PAX West 2019
[Music]